we've been looking at resistant motion
for a little while
resistance so we mostly think of it with
regard to air
but like we said at the beginning
anything any medium
can resist right uh if you think about
this way as well by the way
we've connected this idea of inertia
of an object you know if it's moving it
wants to keep on doing that
or if it's still it wants to keep on
doing that
right well when you think about you know
this medium that you're in
so there's all of this stuff around
which as we said
has its own inertia if you want to think
about another way not just like
a common experience when this object
right that's moving if it's moving
at a certain rate right the faster it
moves
the more quickly it encounters all of
this other stuff right so if you want to
picture it like this like there's one
one big guy right and all of these
little guys uh obviously the little guys
aren't gonna be able to stop the big guy
on their own but on mass right
literally on mass when there's a whole
bunch of them the faster this thing is
going it'll collide with them faster
so it will have to deal with their
inertia faster which is why
they exert more resistance they slow it
down more because there's more of them
okay now we've looked at resistance um
in general but now we want to
particularly think about gravity
not just because it's it's important and
part of our daily experience but because
it just happens so much
like so many questions just introduce
both of these together and they interact
with each other
and the important thing about
understanding how they interact
is that based on the direction of motion
that's what this is about
which way is the body going
based on the direction of motion of the
object
resistance and gravity will interact in
different ways
okay so it's helpful therefore to
consider them as two
separate cases so you don't get them too
mixed up okay
now that being said you don't have to
consider them
as two separate cases it's a little bit
like this do you remember when we did
that um
that example like we had to work out the
total distance of like some object
it got uh there was some force that
accelerated it and then it went to
constant speed
and then a force slowed it down do you
remember that we had something like this
from memory okay now the way i
approached it was i broke it up into
three parts
one two three and then we said okay you
know
from here to here two seconds two to
seven
seven two whatever okay but you don't
have to consider it that way
okay for instance you can consider each
part of the journey as its own thing as
its own case
as it were right and you can say well
i'll make that the origin of case one
i'll make this the origin of case two
and i'll make this the origin of case
three
okay now you can do either you can do
either right the numbers will end up
more or less the same however like why
would you choose one versus the other
why might it be interesting
or useful to us to keep on redefining
the origin can anyone think of reasons
why that might be
useful
if you go back to when we did this
question
um actually we did a couple of them one
of the things that happened was i think
for instance over here
one of them you had to go from seven
seconds up to 8.6 and then you had to do
a definite integral between those
boundaries okay
now because you've got these awkward
numbers it makes it just that little bit
more work to evaluate what the integral
will be
okay in case one where it was zero zero
that integral was so easy because you
just took zero into it right
if the more you can chuck zero into it
the faster your calculations will be
okay obviously that adds in the
additional sort of you gotta keep track
of where you are
and which origin you mean but it's very
useful and that's what we're going to
consider in this case okay
so if we go through this and you get in
a bit of a twist don't freak out you can
still just consider it
as one continuous journey you know i'm
going to talk about the up and the down
part
but it is really useful it is really
useful right
so let's consider just the classic
example
here's the ground okay an object gets
projected upwards
and then it comes back down so i've got
an upward part of the journey
and i've got a downward part of the
journey okay
so for the first part what we usually
say is well let's make the origin where
you begin
that's the projection point where the
object
is projected from okay now but right at
the beginning of um
resisted motion we said it's helpful to
define
resistance right as against the
direction of motion
and i'm defining the direction of motion
is up
so we'll call up the positive direction
right
now therefore think about this resultant
force there's going to be the resistance
and then there's going to be the gravity
we'll deal with gravity first because
gravity is always the same
okay if the positive direction is up
which way is gravity going
oh i should say which what should the
sign of gravity be
it should be negative right so i'm going
to stick in minus
mg there okay
at the same time i've got air resistance
now because i'm going upwards
right which direction is the resistance
force going in
it's going downwards which means it's
also negative okay
so i've got a negative here now just as
a little note
some textbooks will put this is about
resistance right so they'll sometimes
call that
r r for resistance okay uh just
personally
like this is just a um a very
whatever your preference type thing is i
don't like to call it uh i prefer to
call it
f r i'll tell you why um in all these
kinds of questions particularly what
we're about to look at
you know there's pronumerals flying
everywhere right and it's so hard to
keep track of everything
i like to see this because it reminds me
that this is a force
and it's the force that comes from
resistance so that's just the way my
brain works if you're like i just want
less letters
go ahead and call it r whatever you like
so this might be
kv or mkv or kb squared you get the idea
it'll vary depending on the question
okay now um i'm going to get to an
acceleration equation here
so i've got m a over here that's what
the force is
right minus mg minus
that force okay so if i wanted just
acceleration just
x double dot okay what that is is
both of these are negative both are
negative so i'm going to slap a minus
sign out the front
then you've got the force due to
gravity i'm dividing my mass and then
you've got the force
due to resistance okay so far so good
so there's an acceleration equation
let's have a look at the downward part
of the journey now okay
so we've gotten all the way up to here
right and then velocity equals zero and
then we start to fall back down
we redefine the origin okay we make this
the origin that's my highest point
okay because i'm probably going to work
out i want to work out how far i've gone
so i'm going to integrate from zero to
whatever
okay so we call this the the highest
point in the journey
okay now that my direction of motion is
downward i'm going to make that the
positive direction so that my resistance
is opposing now
okay so i've got down now
as the positive direction okay now let's
replay this
gravity i've redefined the direction so
what sign should gravity
have it should be positive so we
m g okay
now because resistance always opposes
the direction of motion
it always opposes this is going to be
minus f
r again okay so i guess if you were
considering you know this example before
if you wanted to consider this all as
one journey don't redefine the origin
instead of having the resistance being
negative both times
you'd have the gravity being negative
both times because it'd be down and
down all right so you've got
m a over here
so now my acceleration equation when i
divide by
mass i don't have a um they're not both
negative okay so i'm just going to call
this
g minus this
okay so just before we leave this and
have a look at an example
let me make a couple of notes have a
look at this right see this situation
both gravity and resistance are both
pulling the object downward
okay they're both both acting in this
direction okay
so therefore if you wanted to overcome
this right you would need some other
kind of force
something in here right that was really
really positive in order to overcome
both of those
okay now this is what we do when objects
try and
escape from the pull of gravity right so
you see these enormous rockets and
they're huge
they're huge rockets for two reasons
number one you've got to overcome
this enormous force right so you need a
really powerful engine
but really powerful engines burn a lot
of fuel right so you're like hey i'll
put fuel on
but that's a problem because the more
fuel you've got the more mass you've got
so then this force gets even bigger so
you know like
whatever percentage this enormous rocket
full of fuel
is what's driving you know like a tiny
satellite or a tiny space shuttle to get
it off the ground
okay to get it to escape velocity right
so that's that's what you would do in
this situation
you'd need an enormous amount of thrust
to overcome these forces and the mass
that you're going to have because you
have been a lot of fuel okay
secondly have a look at this situation
now that we're going downwards okay
i've got this picture where it's like
well i'm going to hit the ground i know
of course eventually you'll hit the
ground
but imagine you are very very far away
from the ground
okay so uh here you are down here
okay so you've got this object that's
plummeting down okay
now have a look particularly at this
line
in oh yeah in here i think it's probably
the best example
have a look at it okay now because in
this downward part of the journey
gravity and resistance are now fighting
each other
okay they're they're opposing each other
at some point you can see
right it'll get faster and faster and
faster and faster
but eventually this will become equal to
this
right the air resistance will equal to
the gravitational force
okay because it's not going to get
faster and faster forever right it's not
going to fall and i'm just going to keep
on
accelerating eventually these two will
be equal
okay now consider what happens when
uh yeah i'll do it here when
the air resistance is equal to the
gravitational force
what happens well this
over here will be zero right
and according to the first law of motion
when you have a resultant force of zero
what's going to happen it's just going
to be constant speed it's not at rest is
it
it's uniform straight line motion okay
and when that happens you're going to
have
if it's a force of zero you're going to
have an acceleration of zero
right so when you integrate up with
respect to time
right you have a constant velocity and
we call that
the terminal velocity okay that's as
fast as it's ever going to go
right you can also see by the way
that um the bigger this guy is the
bigger the gravitational force
the faster this is going to be right so
if you've got an object that's
accelerating things faster
then your terminal velocity will also be
faster okay